in brighton clubbers are out in force
[Music]
and some of the police
it's the only force in the country led
by women and here they're taking women's
safety seriously
you'll be seeing show their presence it
makes people feel safer
yeah
and if you are
in trouble
over a million pounds is being injected
to make streets safer
and patrols like these are being stepped
up
what's happened tonight then what have
you been up to
preventing crime acting as a deterrent
and escorting vulnerable people to safe
spaces
i'll probably get her in the wheelchair
in a minute
this is all about ensuring women are
protected but in order to do this the
conversation needs to start with men
sexual violence needs to end
do you think it's up to women or do you
think it's up to us
the message is clear
violence against women should be a male
issue and sussex hope videos like these
will encourage men to call it out
if i'm being honest and vulnerable like
i have once also been one of those lads
that would
make these inappropriate comments and
this this talk needs to happen to make
that change because it's not fair it's
not the responsibility of women
to protect themselves against men or
other sort of predators out there it's
the responsibility of society and of men
in society the campaign was launched by
katie bourne the woman who oversees
sussex police
everybody recognizes this is a one of
those moments in
in time for policing if they don't do
something now they could you know stand
the risk losing the public forever on
this
but even the power of being a police and
crime commissioner does not shield her
from misogyny
it's really difficult you know i'm a
public figure and to a certain extent
you expect a lot of brick bats to come
your way but when uh individuals these
are men fixate on you it makes life
really um really challenging and
certainly i've had my own experiences at
the moment i have three men who have
custodial sentences because of stalking
against me in that respect i'm trying to
use everything that i've learned in
order to make things better for others
and this determination shows
this all female senior team is leading
the way in efforts to protect women
this month a safe space app will be
launched and the force are asking people
to share personal experiences
nationally a new policing framework will
soon be published it will focus on
pursuing perpetrators and creating safe
spaces for women all whilst building
back trust in the police
sherman freeman powell sky news